overwhelmed with your cable equipment
and what's with the complicated install
it's impossible to know what goes where
attention and cablement victims if
you're feeling entangled but with your
cable box then Hulu Plus live TV has an
announcement for you we're proud to
introduce the cable be gone spray just
one pump
makes your cable stressors go away just
spray you won't believe your eyes one
spray sends cable back to the Stone Age
the uses for this Wonder sprayer
practically endless just be careful not
to spray Grandma call today and switch
to Hulu Plus live TV with over 85 live
channels plus Hulu's entire streaming
library and access to Disney plus and
ESPN there's a better way to stream
break free from your encablement and
call Hulu Plus live TV that's one eight
five five Hulu now okay we'll be going
straight only this year Robert's
imagination not available in any
location may lead to excessive laughter
entertainment and binge watching Hulu
Plus live TV
[Music]